los dedos
el abuelo de rigor murió el 26 de abril
en mariupol ciudad mártir de ucrania
un shock para su nieto de ocho años que
eligió contar el horror de la guerra en
un diario con palabras pero también con
dibujos como estos tanques rusos a lo
largo de las páginas una misma idea la
muerte puede golpear en cualquier
momento
estas son dos de nuestras vecinas nadie
y galia ambas han sido enterradas la
primera hermana murió y la otra un poco
más tarde esto es lo último que dibujó
ligor
durante varias semanas llegó su hermana
y su madre fueron obligados a vivir en
un búnker porque su casa fue destruida
por un misil ruso estaba ubicada cerca
de la fábrica asustan
estas pocas imágenes tomadas con un
teléfono móvil dan una mejor idea del
calvario que tuvo que sufrir la familia
golpeada hasta la médula
estoy herido en la espalda mi piel está
desgarrada mi hermana tiene un corte en
la cabeza
y mi madre tiene músculos desgarrados en
la mano y un agujero en la pierna
durante unos días la familia de llegar
ha encontrado refugio en sap orilla a
100 kilómetros al norte de mariupol
ahora esperar llegar a la capital kiev